hey guys it's max for max tech we just
got our hands on the new beats power
beats Pro and a lot of people are
comparing them to the air pods but to me
personally they seem much closer and
much more similar to Samsung's Galaxy
buds so that's what we're gonna be doing
today we're gonna compare all the
features the sound quality take a look
at the different specs and the decide
which one is a better value let's start
out by getting them out of this really
nice packaging here we got another box
now I can go this way and here we go
interesting and hope we got a little
drawer here I think I was gonna say
that's it but let's set that down that's
surprisingly heavy ok and on the inside
we have a Black Lightning connector just
like with the iMac Pro and adjustable
ear tips because they do seal into your
ear canals holding the case in my hands
the first kind of thing that comes to my
mind is wow this is both heavy and very
large now I knew it was definitely
larger than an ear pods case but I
didn't think it was gonna be this big it
literally is the size of my palm and I
have really large hands it kind of looks
like a air pod case the shape that has
but it actually opens up upwards like
this there you go
actually feels really nice and
satisfying like there's a little bit of
tension on the hinge let's grab the
galaxy bud case and this is kind of
funny holding these side-by-side the
galaxy buds are a little bit bulkier
than the air pods but this thing is
literally I don't know maybe six times
the size at least four times if you
count volume but probably six or even
more and as far as weight I mean there's
also no comparison this thing feels
really substantial the galaxy buds use a
USB type-c connector whereas the power
beats Pro use lightning I really wish
they would have went with the USB type-c
as well I mean I know it's an Apple own
company but almost everything is going
to USB type-c now one very odd thing is
that the power beats Pro do not come
with wireless charging the galaxy buds
that are much less expensive have that
built in in this very convenient the new
air pots have wireless charging and this
thing is more expensive than both of
those if the case is much larger but it
does not have it built in it makes no
sense to me the only thing I can really
think of is maybe they want to save a
feature for the next you know later
version
let's pop open the case there's actually
a sticker in here says to keep the
earbuds inside the case we see power
beats Pro let's hit connect and there we
go the case is 65% and the actual buzz
themselves are 59% easy as that that's a
very easy very nice setup the galaxy
buds aren't that bad not as convenient
but you just go into your Bluetooth
settings they pop up instantly and they
connect actually very very quickly if
you as an Android phone they have a
similar type of setup as Apple's just
less convene you have to go through
multiple steps to give it a bunch of
permissions and then download an app now
let's get to the part that probably most
of you guys are curious about and that
is the sound quality now I've been using
these Galaxy buds for over a month now
ever since they were released and I
really really like them even for people
who use iPhones actually made a
dedicated video on the user experience
you guys can click that car to buff you
wanna check it out or use the little box
after this video so I am very familiar
with them but with that said I still
want to open them up put them in my ears
we're gonna start with the Galaxy buds
and then I'll flip over to the power
beats Pro okay good amount of bass a lot
better than the air pods
so we're talking a lot of music playing
it sounds good I'm used to these
headphones I've actually been using them
more than my ear pods recently
alright this very interesting I haven't
used these kinds of headphones in a
while I kinda have to wrap them around
there we go alright a little bit louder
nice bass which you would expect there
beats the guitar sound nice the the
vocals sound very similar
okay so that's definitely a much quicker
insertion process okay a little bit less
bass vocals sounded very similar I am
very surprised by how similar that
sounds I was not expecting that honestly
I was expecting me kinda be blown away
because of the price tag these are both
switching instantly even though we're
using an iPhone okay let's switch to
another song that is way too close for
me now I'm listening to an electronic
track that has deeper bass and kind of
higher more crisp highs so this is kind
of a song that pushes these headphones
further and they still are very close
I'm been listening to the galaxy buzz
and they sound really good the galaxy
buds sound good for the money
switching back to the beats though this
is where I could tell that the highs are
more crisp yeah the bass is much more
prominent but the sound quality of the
bass is definitely better the vocals are
a little more clear and I got to turn
down the volume
but these definitely sound good these
definitely sound better with this song
both the previous track it was really
hard to tell a difference I am gonna be
doing a full review on these so make
sure you guys are subscribed with those
notifications enabled I'm gonna listen
to a lot more music podcasts videos and
then I'll cover the sound quality in
detail in that follow-up video along
with everything else but just as far as
comfort I'll touch on that again these
ear tips are a lot thicker and you
definitely feel them a lot more winging
there in your eager along with having
kind of the plastic go over and around
your ear I think if you're working out
or doing something else you'll probably
forget about it after a few minutes but
initially you're right when you put them
in the galaxy buds are definitely much
more comfortable the ear tips are softer
and thinner so you don't feel them
inside your ear canal as much and these
also have these little adjustable little
wings so they can kind of seal in
properly so these will work just fine if
you're working out at least doing normal
activity as far as controls the galaxy
buds have a touchpad on the side if
you're using them with an iOS device it
will invoke Siri and you can ask her to
turn up the volume switch the song you
can also double tap to do so along with
that if you have an Android smartphone
you'll actually have other options you
can add more bass or add more treble
what you can do
with an iPhone and you can manage your
notifications and do find my earbud so a
lot more control with an Android device
but I'm comparing it with my iPhone here
whereas the power beats they have
physical controls so you have a little
rocker over here you can invoke Siri you
can turn up the volume skip songs you
can just say hey Siri and then Siri will
invoke and respond to you right next to
those physical buttons we have a little
cutout for the microphone that is facing
upwards and they are on both just like
they are on the Galaxy buds but the
galaxy buds microphones are larger and
they face down let's go ahead and do a
microphone test this is a microphone
quality test in a phone call with a
power beats Pro this is a microphone
quality test within a phone call with
the Galaxy buds go ahead and let us know
down in the comments section below which
one of these earbuds microphones sound
better to you now what about protection
from water or sweat the Galaxy buds come
with an IP x2 rating means they are kind
of sweat proof they could withstand a
little bit of splashing whereas the
power beats Pro come with an IP x4
rating meaning they're also resistant to
sweat with light splashing so neither of
them are truly waterproof you don't want
to dunk them or drop them but the power
beats do have a little bit more
protection now let's get to the last
part of our comparison and that is
battery life this is where the power
beats Pro really stand out looking at
just the buds themselves the Samsung's
Galaxy buds they last for about 6 hours
when are you listening to music compared
to nine hours with the power beats Pro
the cases the Galaxy buds case will hold
up to seven hours of additional charge
compared to 24 hours plus with the
powers beats pro case and that
definitely makes sense because of how
huge and heavy it is but one standout
feature with the power beats Pro is its
fast charge both of these have fast
charging capabilities but with the
Galaxy buds in 15 minutes of charging
you'll get 1.7 hours of play time that's
not too bad but the power beats pro in
just 5 minutes I'll get an hour and a
half worth of charge so these definitely
can charge much faster if you just need
a really quick top off so what are my
final thoughts on this comparison well I
am very surprised with how large this
case is
and let's see as you could tell it's my
first time putting this back in here
there we go now we're getting it in I
definitely knew that this case was quite
large but I didn't think I was gonna be
this large and especially this heavy you
obviously cannot fit this thing in your
pocket and one of the things that I love
about the Galaxy buds and the air pods
is that can happen with me at all times
and just slip him into my jeans and I
don't even notice them they kind of just
get lost there cannot do this with the
powerbeats Pro this has to go into your
laptop bag your gym bag or whatever so
it's a lot less convenience and I think
a lot of people are gonna leave these at
home or in their bag and not always have
them with them so that's definitely a
downside and as far as price I wanted to
leave this for last the galaxy buds they
retail for about a hundred and thirty
dollars but just like many Samsung
products that you can actually find them
for a lower price than that I will have
some links in the video description if
you guys are interested and the new
power beats Pro these things are two
hundred and fifty dollars so it's almost
twice as much so if we take a look at
everything combined you look at the
specifications the features the ease of
use the sound quality the charging the
battery life pack all of that together
and then try to decide which one is
better honestly I have got to give it to
the galaxy buds when you look at the
price point and you look at how good it
is for the price it is such a great
product and along with that it's very
easy to take with you this is probably
the better choice for most people let me
know your guys's thoughts down in the
comment section below I'm gonna have
links to both and if you want to see how
these work with an iOS devices little
quirks my full experience click that
little video over there if you want to
check it out if you guys want to
subscribe hit that little circle above
enable notifications I will be putting
this to the test
try not a bunch of music videos podcasts
all that stuff and making a full review
this man max max tech and I'll see you
in the next video
you